e aí galera regional tudo para você e
também tem também toda a imagem na tela
e finné o barein dói levantar dino o que
hoje não é breve pois a galera que foi o
que eu fiz em parnaíba e dia 22 agora em
novembro dia 22 em são luís de novo no
centro de convenções
galera eu quero que seja desse nível
aqui pra cima eu quero que são luís me
enche de orgulho ingressos sendo
vendidos no total o ingresso no rio poty
hotel
quer saber mais alguma coisa sobre o
show solo explica que no primeiro na
descrição do vídeo beleza pois é eu
estava fazendo um show e quando eu
voltei ativa a notícia de que a nossa
presidenta que se refere que a gestante
sem precedentes foi e até aí tudo bem
porque eu não tenho essa portaria todos
a não ser que a taxa não vou tatuar
dilma no meu medo não sou só hashtag s
no de voz não é não só desse tipo de
pessoa por mim como fazer um show eu não
exercia o meu direito de cidadão de
votar né que não devo votar ou
justificar meu voto eu cheguei que essa
brincadeira tinha ganhado é pô
parabéns a dilma é pena por é só que aí
você sabe que eu sou uma pessoa de
internet e eu conheço uma pessoa
internet eu passo o dia inteiro na
internet quando acontece a água acabou
bbb e internet só se pode beber ea amor
de voz e internet só se fala de voto
passando na sky o filme monstro do lago
ness na internet sofá de regina casé é
muito normal e vai ter na internet
estava aqui falando de dilma foge a esta
eleição pode ser que falam de
preconceito nordeste na inegociável piro
aí do futebol foi tudo chegou uma galera
xingando nordeste de burro de idiota
porque
satanás chegou a galera não é completo
cetim do nordeste no nordeste é tudo
burro que reelegeu a corrupção ao
nordeste num povo imbecil meio depois de
reclamar um destino que não têm água que
morre de servir e ainda faz cagada nas
urnas é nem assim não chega porque
nordeste nordeste nem um pouco se você
mexe com uns e mexeu foi contudo não
defendo dilma e no df dodf eu não sou de
tilintando tem um partido nem das
pessoas que dizem que as pessoas nova
versão botei eleita dilma elas estão
falando basicamente de três coisas
corrupção segundo de cuba e terceiro do
bolsa família então vamos lá primeiro
corrupção ok roubaram o que desviar
dinheiro do mensalão tá bom mas vamos
combinar que aécio neves não é nenhum
espírito santo sem sabe né sei se eles
não sabem né
sigam cúpula sobre cuba não vou falar
porque não sei não posso falar para o
torcedor do boca não quer dizer que eu
não tô sabendo é verdade ele é ser o
bolsa família o brasileiro não quer mais
trabalhar porque tem bolsa família bolsa
família um sustentar vagabundos
vagabundo agora quer fazer 56 equipa
ganhar dinheiro do bolsa família não
quer mais trabalhar mas não é agora que
eu vou mostrar pra vocês quem são os
ignorantes e os bulls tem vagabundo
rejeitado pelo bolsa família tem
vagabundo sustentado pelo bolsa família
tem vagabundo fazendo fiador dar só uma
pegadinha do bolsa família tem vagabundo
adoidado fazendo fifa pegadinha do
flamengo fazendo que transam toda hora e
só que além dos vagabundos que são tudo
sujeitar pelo bolsa família tem gente
pobre que precisou muito bolsa família
para mim e eu graças ao meu bom deus
graças a deus graças a deus enquanto
morei com meu pai com minha mãe eu nunca
passei fome na minha vida e meus pais
sempre trabalhar para colocar acima de
tudo dentro de casa o miami podia ficar
sem comer mal fina ficava sem comer não
só como é que o pai trabalhava vendendo
o remédio interior a galera do interior
não tinha como sair pra poder na cidade
fazer a consulta que acontece meu pai lá
os a fdd pironi vendia para a galera e
eu ia com meu pai sabe que eu via no
interior onde você não vê e ouve a gente
pobre pobre passando fome chora não tem
jeito interior se você fala em bolsa
família pessoa até chora sim o fim dela
tá vivo hoje é colocar o bolsa família a
gente que por causa de um bolso
iria conseguir comprar uma coisa para
comer gente que por causa do bolsa
família consiga comprar um caderno e
lápis eu posso pagar por fico feliz com
essa é a diferença da ignorância de você
e falar mal do nordeste o povo do
nordeste que voltou voltou pensando
pobre e voltou pensando foi na pessoa
que passa necessidade a pessoa que
precisou sair essa ignorância de vocês
botar em primeiro lugar o vagabundo e
depois pensar no pobres milhão de
pessoas saíram da pobreza extrema foi no
nordeste porque aqui a galera precisava
isso aí quem sabe quem vê pé do coral
azul com ar condicionado ligado vidro
fumê ninguém vendo ver quem foi lá quem
foi lá vem antes de me chamar de
ignorante avalia a ignorância de vocês e
fez o primeiro do pobre não adianta
falar do nordeste não saber que você
pode falar mal pode falar mal fala mal
do nordeste falar mal das pessoas no
nordeste um dia que você ganha no
nordeste precisar de um caso para ficar
aqui vai ter que o povo daqui é bom é
acolhedor e é um pouco carinhoso e se
fala muito não deve ser uma regra aqui
pra não me afasta noronha fala mal do
nordeste é do ipea fernando otto aquecem
no nordeste é com orgulho precisão
estamos aí abraça todo mundo um beijo
espero que vocês tenham entendido que
não só a favor de dilma em favor de
aécio eu estou aqui por ninguém nem por
nenhum partido político eu só me
invoquei com esse tipo de ignorância que
você pensa primeiro no pobre depois um
vagabundo ajuda quem precisa encarar o
amor valeu obrigado ea nós